the prime minister of Canada Justin
Trudeau and his wife Sophie joining
members of the public in solemn
contemplation as they pay their final
respect to the queen
Anthony albanazi the Prime Minister of
Australia doing the same
both men have met King Charles as the
new monarch receives heads of government
and governors from the Realms and
Commonwealth Nations drawing them close
at a difficult time department
they are just some of the many arriving
in London ahead of the Queen's funeral
on Monday
some 500 foreign dignitaries
representing nearly 200 nations are
going to be attending the Queen's
funeral simply managing all their
movements and keeping them safe is going
to be a huge task
to help with Logistics and security many
are being asked to arrive at Westminster
Abbey in buses provided by the UK
government they and the public will be
protected by some 10 000 uniform police
officers from every corner of the
country snipers will be stationed on
rooftops and surveillance drones will
fly overhead
and from the Welsh Cavalry to the Royal
Air Force more than 2 500 uniformed
military personnel will also be on hand
in terms of the cost and scale a close
comparison is likely to be William and
Kate's wedding security for that event
cost nearly 6.4 million pounds
but the state funeral is a major
diplomatic operation too it's enormous
when you think about it almost every
single state visit by a head of state
takes up a huge amount of time in the
planning and Arrangements uh the detail
that has to be gone into to look after
visiting heads of state properly if you
imagine that multiplied by the numbers
of people who are coming you can imagine
the exercise the counter factor to that
of course is the way in which the
preparation has been done over such a
long time
prime minister Liz truss has been
meeting a small number of counterparts
achieving a country residence belonging
to the government these are being
treated as private meetings rather than
formal bilateral encounters
many won't be extended the same courtesy
she is expected to speak to the
controversial Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman on the phone Sky
News understands that he will meet King
Charles but given concerns about the
human rights record of his country will
not attend the funeral
it's another tiny piece of a complicated
puzzle being assembled under intense
pressure and scrutiny in a time of
national Mourning
Hannah Thomas Peters Sky News in
Westminster